Monday morning we have the Oscar
nominations are you just like trying to
see how it come when it comes
call me when it's over yeah well it's
over and Jennifer Lopez has been snubbed
by the Oscars I think these things are
just a little bit nerve-wracking you
know I don't know what it is anyway it
goes on Monday the nominees for this
year's Academy Awards were announced and
one name was noticeably missing JLo
the journey of this film has been such a
labor of love and to even be in the
conversation that you're talking about
is just a dream come true the 50 year
old wasn't listed in the Best Supporting
Actress category for her role as Ramona
the ringleader of a band of strippers
turned scammers in hustlers it's like
robbing a bank except you get the keys
are you in if Jennifer had been
nominated she would have swept noms at
all the big award shows this season but
instead she was passed over in the
category for Kathy Bates Scarlett
Johansson Florence Pugh Margot Robbie
and Laura Dern Laura beat out Jennifer
at both the Golden Globes and the
Critics Choice Awards et caught up with
Jen on the red carpet at the Golden
Globes where she got emotional talking
about her nomination do you remember the
last time you were here nominated when
22 years ago for your greatest role ever
it was it was it was 22 years ago and it
was I can't believe I'm here what would
you tell that girl 22 years ago there
was wandering on the carpet like oh it's
a little movie Selena who lost that day
I tell her don't give up don't give up
keep going it doesn't matter what
happens tonight you're still a winner
you cry shut up but when et was a JLo in
September she didn't even want to talk
about all the Oscar buzz surrounding her
role in Hustler's nobody even likes to
say it I don't want to jinx it
[Laughter]
it's incredible you know you you sign on
to these movies you give it your all you
do all you can you know learning the the
pole dancing the emotional journey of
what these girls go through me playing a
character like I've never played I'm a
real badass here a real bad girl I mean
she is so far from Who I I think I'm
tough but I'm not tough and while she
may not have a shot at taking home Oscar
gold this year when to be a great show
what can I tell you we're gonna try to
get the best Super Bowl show ever you
know she is set to perform at the Super
Bowl halftime show with Shakira I'm
ready are you ready yeah I'm ready I'm
excited about it yeah I mean it's me and
Shakira she's carrying half the load I
feel good oh so you're like I'm good I'm
good I'm good no I'm excited we've been
working on an amazing show for everybody
and you know it's a few weeks out go
back to rehearsal right tomorrow morning
it is what it is yeah I'd say she's
still winning what do I I'm not gonna
complain about except a few sore muscles
from rehearsal nothing I mean my life
right now is just so amazing my personal
life you know my kids everything
everything is just in a great place and
I feel really lucky but JLo wasn't the
only one snubbed by the Oscars this year
Beyonce wasn't nominated for The Lion
King soundtrack spirit frozen to was
overlooked in the Best Animated Feature
Film category and a much smaller film
the farewell was completely shut out of
this year's race including awkwafina's a
breakthrough dramatic performance in the
Best Actress race us star Lupita Nyong'o
was shut out Adam Sandler didn't land in
the Best Actor race for his role in
uncut gems and Eddie Murphy was also
left out of the category for his
performance in Dolomites is my name oh
and then there was this yeah no women
were honored for Best Director a theme
of this award season ah but seriously
you guys JLo my heart is broken of
course you can count on et to bring you
all the latest on jennifer so make sure
to keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Holly Stephens bye for now
[Music]